ب
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
مستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم الله
الرحمن قل هو الله
احد الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر
[Silence]
سمع
الله لمن
حمده اللهم انت الحق ووعدك الحق ولقاؤك
الحق وجنه الحق ونار الحق وساعه الحق
ونبينا حق ونبينا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
حق اللهم بك اسلمنا وعليك توكلنا واليك
نبنا وبك
خاصمنا فاغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما
اخرنا فانت المقدم انت الموخر وانت على كل
شيء قدير
اللهم اهدنا في من
هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا فيمن
توليت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت وكنا واصرف
عنا برحمتك شر ما
قضيت انك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يزل
من واليت
ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا وان لم تغفر لنا وترحمنا لنكونن من
الخاسرين اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو
عنا اللهم انك اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب
العفو فاعف
عنا اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو
فعفونا اللهم اعتق رقابنا من
النار ورقاب
والدينا وذريتنا
وازواجنا وارحام
واولادنا
وابائنا
وامهاتنا
ومشايخنا
واصدقائنا من النار وادخلنا جنه مع
الابرار يا عزيز يا
غفار اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا يا سابق
الفوط ويا كاس عظام لحما بعد الموت اغفر
لجميع الموت
المسلمين الذين شهدك
بالوحدانيه والبيك
بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك
اللهم اغفر لهم
وارحمهم وعافهم واعف عنهم واكرم نزلهم
ووسع مدخلهم واغسلهم بالماء ثلج والبرد
ونقهم من الذنوب والخطايا كما ينقى الثوب
الابيض من
الدنس ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما احييتنا واجعلهم الوارث
منا واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على
من
عادانا ولا تصلط علينا بذنوبنا من لا يخاف
فينا ولا
يرحمنا اللهم عز جارك وجل ثناؤك وتقدست
اسماؤك اللهم لا يرد امرك ولا يحزن جندك
سبحانك
وبحمدك اللهم اد المسجد الا الى رحاب
المسلمين اللهم اد المسجد الاقصى الى رحاب
المسلمين وارزقنا فيه صلاه قبل الممات
اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم انصر اخواننا المستضعفين
في كل
مكان اللهم انصر اللهم انصر اخوان
المستضعفين في فلسطين وفي غزه وفي سودان
وفي وفي السين وفي
البرما وفي كشمير وفي الهند اللهم ايدهم
بجنودك لا يعلم جنودك الا انت اللهم انصر
الاسلام والمسلمين ودمر اعداء الدين يا
قوي يا عزيز اللهم تقبل صيامنا اللهم تقبل
صيامنا اللهم تقبل صيامنا وصلاتنا وصلاتنا
وصلاتنا اللهم تقبل قراننا اللهم تقبل
قراننا اللهم تقبل قراننا اللهم اجعل له
حجه لنا ولا حجه علينا يا كريم يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم ذكرنا منه ما
نسينا وعلمنا منه ما جهلنا وارزقنا تلاوته
اناء الليل واطراف النهار على الوجه الذي
يريك النار يا حي يا قيوم يا حي يا قيوم
يا حي يا قيوم برحمتك نستغيث برحمتك
نستغيث
برحمتك نستغيث اصلح لنا شاننا ولا ت الى
انفسنا طرفه عين لا اله الا انت سبحانك
انا كنا من
الظالمين لا اله الا انت سبح سبحانك انا
كنا من
الظالمين لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا
من
الظالمين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقن عذاب النار وقن عذاب
القبر وقن عذاب جهنم وكنا شر فتنه المحيا
الممات وكنا شر فتنه المسيح دجال ربنا
تقبل منا انك انت السميع العليم وتب علينا
يا مولانا انك انت التواب
الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحمتك ارحم الراحمين
[Silence]
الله
اكبر ان